[Musik]
das ist eine scan zufrieden 208 groß nba
basketballstar rechts davon ich etwas
kleiner john kosmalla ich lebe wie der
riese neben mir in new york und wollte
eigentlich einen film über einen
basketballer mit schweizer wurzeln
machen
heute reihen sie sich in die
prestigeträchtige liste der
menschenrechts helden ein und ich
gratuliere ihnen die internationale
gemeinschaft und meine gemeinschaft die
uiguren dank nehmen ich bin stolz ihnen
im namen des genfer
menschenrechtskommission wort für das
jahr 2022 zu verleihen
mister freedom kommen sie bitte nach
vorn um ihren preis entgegenzunehmen
dass ich nun mit einem nba star an einem
menschenrechts gipfel in genf gelandet
bin ist der epilog einer abenteuerlichen
reise in den usa in die türkei und die
schweiz
lasst uns mit basketball beginnen am 8
februar warst du im park recycling
dunklen und hast mein heimteam die
brooklyn nets besiegt du hast einen
großartigen drei punkte korb erzielt
sein letzter treffer in ein bmi
was bedeutet es dir heute diese
auszeichnung zu erhalten
heute ist ein sehr besonderer tag denn
es ist das erste mal dass sich die
vereinigten staaten verlassen habe seit
die türkische regierung mir den reisen
pass weggenommen und meinen namen auf
die interpol liste gesetzt hat aber ich
wollte hier her kommen und an dieser
wundervollen veranstaltung teilnehmen
vor zwei monaten war ich bei den boston
celtics in der nba wir haben nie eine
meisterschaft gewonnen aber glaube hier
mit meinem neuen team mit meinen neuen
helden meinen neuen champions hier
können wir eine meisterschaft gewinnen
denn sie sind furchtlos
alle diktatoren draußen sollten sich in
acht nehmen
[Musik]
anfang jahr in boston enes kanter
frieden spielt für die boston celtics
mein plan ein filmisches porträt über
den 29 jährigen zu drehen
mein name ist enes kanter friede ich
spiele für die boston celtics in der nba
und das ist mein elftes jahr
ich bin in zürich geboren ich blieb nur
meine ersten lebensmonate dort dann
zogen wir in die türkei wo ich 16 jahre
lang lebte und dann kam ich nach amerika
doch heute ist alles anders
kenter frieden kritisierte
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china und
zahlte dafür einen hohen preis die
houston rockets verzichteten auf ihren
neuen centerspieler enes kanter friedens
nba karriere war zu ende
wenn das der grund dafür ist dass die
nbh mich aus der liga wirft kann ich
nicht dagegen tun
irgendjemand muss das hier einfach tun
könnte frieden kritisierte china sowie
die nba und den sportartikel giganten
nike für deren geschäfte mit china
es wäre sehr egoistisch von mir den mund
zu halten und mich auf mein eigenes
leben zu konzentrieren hier mein geld zu
verdienen ein gutes leben zu führen
als sie meinen vater ins gefängnis
gesteckt haben wir gar nicht die
menschen besser zu verstehen
erst jetzt ahne ich was all die
politischen gefangenen auf der ganzen
welt durchmachen müssen
freiheit frieden eines kämpfers neues
programm nach der nba wurde anlässlich
seiner einbürgerung in den usa auch sein
neuer beiname
glückwunsch sie sind jetzt bürger der
vereinigten staaten
[Applaus]
nach wasser und luft ist freiheit noch
immer etwas vom wichtigsten für den
menschen darum ist es so wichtig für
mich das wort freiheit zu einem teil von
mir zu machen
[Musik]
versuchen sie nicht einfach mit diesem
namen eine eigene marke für sich zu
schaffen
wenn es die menschen inspiriert vor
allem unsere junge generation dann ja
denn das ist alles was mich interessiert
ich will dass alle kinder da draußen
ohne angst aufwachsen können
um enes kanter und seine geschichte
besser zu verstehen reise ich in die
schweiz hier am zürcher tierspital
schrieb sein vater mehmet kanter anfang
der 90er jahre seine dissertation
john peter ist wissenschaftliche
zeichnerin am tierspital sie arbeitete
damals mit mit kanter zusammen und
vermittelt mir so eine neue perspektive
auf enes kanter freedom
ich sehe mit stark in den augen seines
seines sohnes er hat extrem die gleichen
augen wie sein vater
damit hat das wirklich so dunkle und und
seine haare waren auch so
außergewöhnlich dieses schwarz und und
so wie man es bei uns nicht sieht aus
dem sohn des begeisterten tier
mediziners wurde ein
menschenrechtsaktivist
für mich war mit nicht
darum als ich das gehört habe war ich
schon sehr erstaunt
was du wenn ich jetzt mir das überlegen
das ist ja eigentlich nicht der sinn von
einem porträt jemanden ans licht zu
bringen und er und sein vater die haben
ja was zu sagen die haben ja was zu
erzählen
mein vater hatte große träume wollte
große dinge tun
dafür steht die schweiz
viele menschen in der türkei gehen nach
deutschland
aber mein vater wollte etwas anderes
machen als
er in die schweiz gekommen war sprach er
englisch aber kein einziges wort deutsch
er lernte die sprache von grund auf das
inspiriert mich bis heute
hans meyer professor der anatomischen
veterinärmedizin arbeitete anfang der
90er jahre ebenfalls mit mehr mit kannte
am tierspital und erinnert sich gut an
den doktoranden aus der türkei
dass ich jetzt
die situation
im original druck von
gebiet mit meiner frau und meinem sohn
der hier in zürich geboren war
als ich ein kleines kind war erforschte
er all diese tiere und ich war immer
sehr neugierig und fragte meinen vater
immer was machst du
er war immer für mich da er hat immer
versucht mir zu sagen dass er vor sturm
heilmittel gegen krankheiten zu finden
damit kam
1991 jahren unsere institute vorher
hatte er ein jahr lang wohl sprachen
noch etwas deutschen englisch gelernt
ich habe ihn als stillen forschenden
typen erlebt der sehr nett zu jedem mann
war
[Musik]
am 20 mai 1992 wurde jenes in zürich
geboren der spätere nba spieler war das
erste kind von gülsüm und mimik kanter
die türkische familie lebte in der
schweiz ein sehr bescheidenes leben
[Musik]
um mehr über jenes kärnten und seine
eltern zu erfahren spüre ich in zürich
seebach einen ehemaligen nachbarn vom
vater mit kante auf
hallo wie geht danke gut
sehr gut komm rein
möchtest du mir gern
stephen smith ist amerikaner lebt aber
seit über 30 jahren in zürich
[Musik]
das ist mein sohn till
stephen smith war in den 90er jahren
sänger der zürcher rock band city
flossen und erinnert sich noch genau an
seinen ehemaligen nachbarn mit kanter
der sehr beeindruckt von stephen smith
und seiner musik war
[Musik]
als minute an eines meiner konzerte kam
war er sehr beeindruckt das war ja wie
michael jackson er war so ein
liebenswürdiger klar
er war so warmherzig und sprach immer so
poetisch
er war wirklich eine reizende person
so ein menschen wie ihn vergisst man
nicht und ich sage dir ich habe viele
menschen getroffen aber an ihn erinnere
ich mich immer
stephen smith und mimik kanter wohnten
damals in einem heruntergekommenen
fabrikareal an der zürcher
überlandstrasse schau dir das an
ich glaube ich habe 400 franken im monat
an miete bezahlt es war schon ein altes
gebäude
es ist genau hier oder kran steht da war
es der kern steht auf dem parkplatz
das war's alles ist weg wahrscheinlich
hätten wir es von vorne besser gesagt es
ist genau da da standen jetzt ist er nur
noch eine baustelle
damit hatte kein geld der ging ganz
schmal und sehr bescheiden durchschlägen
zu dieser zeit
als der sohn geboren wurde da weiß ich
das mit sehr sehr stolz vor dass sein
sein sohn dass der erstgeborenen sohn
ist und dass er sehr glücklich über
diese geburt war
als sohn eines 1992 auf die welt
gekommen war zog die junge türkische
familie von der zürcher überlandstrasse
an die langstrasse um mitten ins zürcher
rotlichtviertel
die sogenannten gammel häuser wurden
längst abgerissen und dienten familie
kannte nur kurze zeit als bleibe
denn schon ein jahr später zog es mit
kante mit seiner familie zurück in die
türkei
ines wuchs in istanbul im stadtteil
kadiköy auf einem viertel auf der
asiatischen seite von istanbul
dort wurde auch den jungen ein zwei
meter 08 großes basketball talent die
türkei bald schon zu eng wurde
mit 16 jahren wanderte enes
mutterseelenallein in die usa aus um
dort bei den utah jazz ganz groß ins
basketball geschäft einzusteigen
bald aber verlagerte sich jenes fokus
auf sein heimatland die türkei eines
wurde politisiert
2013 erschütterte ein korruptionsskandal
die türkei präsident erdogan und seine
familie waren darin verwickelt
ich fing an die
menschenrechtsverletzungen in meinem
land auf den sozialen medien zu
kommentieren die politischen gefangenen
und so weiter
die türkische regierung sah das gar
nicht gern denn jede meiner äußerungen
gegen iran
[Musik]
da kam dadurch meine familie unter druck
sie mussten eine erklärung abgeben und
mich als ihren sohn verleugnen das
fahrrad für mich denn es ging um meine
mutter meinem vater
die türkische regierung hat ihnen das
aber nicht geglaubt also kamen die
polizei und durchsuchte unser ganzes
haus sie nahmen telefone computer
laptops ipads mit um herauszufinden ob
ich noch kontakt zu meiner familie habe
sie konnten aber nichts von mir finden
trotzdem haben sie meinen vater für eine
weile ins gefängnis gesteckt aber wir
haben von hier aus viel druck gemacht
dass sie freilich
2016 dann erschütterte ein putschversuch
die türkei teile des militärs versuchten
präsident erdogan zu stürzen
der putsch mißlang und die situation
rund um enes kanter freedom und seine
familie eskalierte
der grund ihre nähe zu vettel agilen ihn
macht präsident erdogan für den
putschversuch verantwortlich
für die regierung erdogan war enes
kanter frieden fordern ein terrorist
2010 annulierte sie seinen türkischen
pass enes kanter frieden wurde
staatenlos
basketball ist populär in der türkei
hier in der arena wo es als junior für
fenerbahce spielte suche ich trotzdem
vergeblich nach spuren des verstoßenen
basketballers und auch kärnten frieden
spiele in den usa wurden in der türkei
zensuriert morddrohungen gegen ihn waren
an der tagesordnung die fans hier
sprechen nicht über ihn
hier wird nur basketball gespielt nicht
politik gemacht wir türken mögen ihn
nicht
[Musik]
jetzt
vor 2015 habe ich mit meiner familie
immer am 20 mai mal geburtstag gefeiert
ich erinnere mich es war der 19 und ich
saß mit meiner mutter meiner schwester
und meinem vater zusammen
ich habe gesagt
ich werde mich gegen einige der
furchtbaren dinge einsetzen die in
unserem land geschehen
und deshalb könnte tier in
schwierigkeiten vielleicht sogar ins
gefängnis kommen
seid ihr bereit dafür
[Musik]
meine mutter sagte wenn du dich für das
einsetzt was richtig ist dann halten wir
dir den rücken frei
ich schaute meinen vater an er sagte
nicht
er wollte mich als den legendären
basketballspieler aus der türkei sehen
der sich nur auf basketball fokussiert
aber als ich jung war verlangten sie von
mir dass ich immer für die wahrheit
einstehe und
in dieser nacht hatte ich einen flug
zurück nach amerika gebucht mein vater
und ich riefen ein taxi vor unser haus
ich habe mich umgedreht meine mutter und
meine schwester winkt mir zu ich sagte
zu mir das ist das letzte mal dass ich
sie sehr und ich vorweg
und es war dann tatsächlich das letzte
mal hatte sich die beiden gesehen habe
zurück in der gegenwart
es ist mitte februar dieses jahres in
washington eines steht ohne team da
verstoßen auch von der nba
ich fühle mich
ich habe das gefühl dass wir etwas
erstaunliches getan haben dass die ganze
welt inspiriert hat
es war einer der größten vielleicht die
größte bewegung für soziale
gerechtigkeit die wir in der nba
geschaffen haben
es war seine kritik an china aufgemalt
auf seinen schuhen die das fass zum
überlaufen brachte freiheit für die
uiguren
völkermord sklaverei blut spiele in
peking
sein zukünftiger club die houston
rockets ließen enes kanter frieden noch
vor seinem ersten einsatz fallen eine
offizielle begründung ist bis heute
ausgeblieben enes kanter frieden
verliert alles
ich packe meine t shirts ein denn jedes
einzelne hat eine große geschichte
hinter sich
ich will sie alle behalten
das sind die schuhe die geschichte
geschrieben haben
einer meiner teamkollegen sagte das sind
die einflussreichsten schuhe die je
geschaffen wurden
ich werde sie alle aufbewahren
ich spreche über die dinge die in der
türkei passieren ich verliere meine
familie ich spreche über die dinge die
in china passieren die ich verliere
meine karriere aber
ich bin immer noch voller hoffnung ich
will noch mindestens sieben jahre
basketball spielen das ist mein ziel ich
bereue nicht
denn es ist auch viel schönes neues
hinzugekommen
ich bin hier in washington um all diese
senatoren und vertreter des
repräsentantenhauses und andere freunde
zu treffen und mit ihnen wieder über
menschenrechte zu sprechen
ich habe viel durchgemacht aber diese
leute haben mich immer unterstützt das
ist meine neue familie
dafür möchte ich mich bedanken
ich spreche seit über zehn jahren über
die türkei habe deswegen keinen einzigen
anruf war
jetzt spreche ich einmal über china
danach klingelt mein telefon fast
stündlich
letztes jahr hatte ich gute statistiken
und jetzt soll ich plötzlich nicht mehr
wissen wie man basketball spielen
enes kanter freedom ist groß doch für
das us amerikanische basketball business
war offenbar nicht groß genug um sein
politisches engagement zu dulden
er ist ein spieler der in der nba eine
rolle finden muss also ich glaube schon
dass es eine rolle gibt für einen
spieler wie ihn der
seine schwächen hat dass das ist klar
der aber auch durchaus immer noch
qualitäten mitbringt die einer
mannschaft weiterhelfen können da
gibt es glaube ich jetzt aus rein
sportlicher perspektive nicht unbedingt
zwei meinungen
gleichzeitig ist es natürlich so und
vielleicht ist es ein bisschen zynisch
aber
sein engagement für gewisse themen für
die menschenrechte für jetzt gerade in
china mit mit tibet zum beispiel dass
das große schlagzeilen gemacht hat auf
der ganzen welt sorgen sicher nicht
dafür dass es einfach hat
der 34 präsident der vereinigten staaten
schaut ihn euch an zwölf jahre china ein
großer markt 5 us dollar die die nba
umsetzt geschätzt also das ist das den
riesensummen die man nicht einfach so
verschenken will und dann kommt da
jemand der zwar solide performance kann
aber nicht der wichtigste und und macht
dann in anführungszeichen ärger
da kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass
sich dann manche teams zweimal überlegen
ob sie den unter vertragen nehmen oder
nicht einen anderen der ähnlich gut
spielt aber weniger
aufwendig in der betreuung ist sozusagen
man sich nicht immer rechtfertigen muss
nach außen gewinn über den chinesischen
geschäftspartnern
stadt mit seinem team durch die stadien
der usa zu touren tauscht enes kanter
frieden sich nun mit endlos über die
zustände in seinem heimatland türkei
oder den umgang chinas mit hongkong
tibet und den
was kannst du uns erzählen wie du zu
dieser arbeit gekommen bist
in den letzten zehn jahren habe ich mich
sehr um die missstände in meinem
heimatland der türkei gekümmert es gibt
dort so viele politische gefangene und
so viele menschenrechtsverletzungen auch
meine familie war betroffen
letzten sommer habe ich an einem
basketball camp für kinder in new york
teilgenommen nach dem camp wollten die
kinder fotos und autogramme von mir
ich erinnere mich an dieses einem
mädchen das zu mir kam ihre eltern
sprachen mich vor allen leuten an
ps sie nennen sich einen
menschenrechtsaktivisten aber sie
sprechen über die uiguren
ich wollte schon seit langem etwas über
dieses thema erfahren
wenn ich heute abend nach hause komme
werde ich mich schlau machen und mich
bei ihnen melden es ist wichtig über
alle menschenrechtsverletzungen zu
sprechen ich danke ihnen für die frage
ich werde nach harten
also habe ich an diesem tag den rest
meines programms gestrichen ich ging
zurück in mein hotel und begann zu
recherchieren
was sich dallas hat mir beinahe das herz
gebrochen und ich habe mich ziemlich
geschämt ich nahm mir vor nun alles zu
tun um darauf aufmerksam zu machen was
mit den uiguren in china passiert
ich habe mich an sportler und andere
leute gewarnt die eine plattform haben
aktivisten prominente rapper sänger bin
auch immer ich kannte
und ich habe ihnen erzählt was mit den
uiguren in china passiert
und sie sagten hör zu ich finde es
großartig was du tust und wofür du dich
einsetzt inspiriert uns und wir lieben
dich wir
unterstützen dich
aber wir können es einfach nicht laut
sagen
fragte warum und sie sagten wir haben
familien zu ernähren oder wir verkaufen
trikots oder schuhe in china ich fragte
und wenn deine mutter deine schwester
deine tochter jetzt in diesen
konzentrationslagern wären würdest du
dann immer noch schweigen
sie hatten keine antwort
jetzt muss einfach eine generation
heranwachsen die moral prinzipien und
werte über geld und geschäft stellt
um dieser generation ein vorbild zu sein
trifft sich heute mit figuren welche die
unterdrückung durch die chinesischen
machthaber am eigenen leib erlebt haben
wir haben hier menschen die in
arbeitslagern in china inhaftiert worden
wie im moment auch meine eigene
schwester ich habe hier ein bild von ihr
sie ist seit 2008 zehn inhaftiert
für uns uhren setzen menschen wie jenes
freedom ihre stimme ein weil wir selbst
uns so machtlos fühlen das gibt uns
etwas hoffnung denn wir wissen nicht
wann wir unsere familienmitglieder
wieder sehen können
das sind unglaubliche schicksale und man
kann auch außenstehende nicht wissen
welche kräfte andere entwickeln wie
leben sie erleben wenn sie
wenn sie so eine last zu tragen haben
finde großartig ausgemacht
es ist anfang april ein großer tag für
enis kärnten frieden
ich begleite ihn in die schweiz wo er
vor 29 jahren geboren wurde sein
heutiges ziel die tibetische gemeinde in
uster hier wird er der den chinesischen
präsidenten jean ping als brutalen
diktator bezeichnet hat wie ein popstar
gefeiert
ich glaube dass es bei den
menschenrechten um empathie geht und
mitgefühl man muss ihren schmerz spüren
man muss fühlen was sie durchmachen
[Musik]
bist du frei
ich bin noch nicht freien ein
weil ich meine familie seit 2015 nicht
mehr sehen durfte
ich kann mich nicht mal mehr an unser
letztes telefongespräch erinnern
man muss für die freiheit kämpfen denn
wenn man sich die geschichte ansieht
weiß man jede diktatur geht einmal zu
ende ich weiß dass chinas kommunistische
partei eines tages am ende sein wird das
erleben wir jetzt gerade und das werden
wir auch in tibet erleben
vielen dank ich weiß das zu schätzen
betet weiter für uns betet weiter für
die nba ich hoffe dass sich noch mehr
sportler orten und das richtige tun denn
es gibt wichtigeres als geld und
geschäfte und ihr seid ein beispiel für
diese dinge prinzipien werte und moral
ich danke euch
freiheit für tibet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie geht es ihnen schön sie
kennenzulernen
ich wünschte ich könnte sagen dass ich
mich an euch erinnere aber das tue ich
nicht
ihr vater hat eine sehr interessante
arbeit über die nebenschilddrüse
geschrieben wir erinnern uns gut an
ihren vater wir geben ihnen diese kopie
ist eine sehr billige kopie denn es gibt
nur zwei originale in der bibliothek
ich habe diese skizze von ihnen gemacht
das ist erstaunlich sie sind sehr begabt
es wäre mir eine ehre und eine freude
ihnen einen abzug davon zu schenken
vielen dank
[Musik]
der kanton zürich mit einer großen
tibetischen gemeinde ist nur eine etappe
von jenes freiheits reise in die schweiz
sein eigentliches ziel ist genf sitz der
uno
hier trifft sich der ehemalige
nba-spieler mit anderen
menschenrechtsaktivistinnen und
aktivisten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich stehe hier vor ihnen um im namen
derer zu sprechen die sprachlos sind
unzensiert werden dann zu schweigen wenn
man seine stimme erheben kann ist ein
verbrechen deshalb will ich mich hier
für die opfer einsetzen denn sie sind
wie sie und ich das volk der vereinten
nationen
mit seiner kritik an china ist kannte
frieden in den usa auch ein liebling von
ultra konservativen geworden studenten
der universität genf wollen mehr dazu
wissen
ich frage mich warum sie sich in den usa
mit mehreren hochrangigen rechtsextremen
aktivisten zusammengetan haben
das heißt nicht dass ich mit ihnen einer
meinung bin ich bekomme diese kritik
aufzuhören
sie müssen verstehen dass es in amerika
eine gruppe von menschen gibt die noch
nie etwas mit einwanderern zu tun hatten
und deshalb möchte ich mit meiner
botschaft all diese menschen erreichen
müssen sie eine stimme kann so viel
verändern und millionen von menschen auf
der welt aufklären es geht um
menschenrechte und ich habe versprochen
jeden teil des landes zu erreichen
zwei monate lang war ich mit enes kanter
frieden unterwegs ich lernte einen
menschen kennen der viel gewagt und viel
verloren hat und so endet unsere
gemeinsame reise statt in einer
basketball arena in den usa am
menschenrechts gipfel in genf was ist
heimat für mich gute frage
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was für mich heimat ist
weil mein heimatland die türkei denkt
dass ich ein terrorist bin
weil ich mich gegenüber diktatur dort
ausgesprochen habe
die welt ist unsere heimat
wenn du nach hause kommst dann sorgst du
dafür dass es sauber dass es perfekt ist
wir erschaffen unsere welt
wir sind eine große familie
wir müssen zusammen kämpfen
ich habe mal etwas interessantes gehört
wenn du ein boxer bist und jemanden so
schlägst du brichst du dir alle finger
aber wenn du ihn so schließt dann
bringst du ihm den kiefer
alle diese aktivisten hier meine freunde
diese helden wir müssen alle zusammen
diesen diktatoren ins gesicht schlagen
und sie zerstören
[Applaus]
brauchst du ein stuhl
[Musik]
wir haben es geschafft
jakarta war ein bisschen nervös aber
weißt du was es ist okay
[Musik]